Now that we've given you an overview and
established a strategic mindset,
we'll go through each LinkedIn section.
Let's begin with the professional
profile picture.
The picture though technically optional,
is highly recommended.
It's your first chance to communicate
that you are friendly, likeable and
trustworthy.
It also helps ensure that you
are human and not a robot.
A strong profile image
should look like you.
It should be a recent photo that
reflects how you would look if you
showed up for an interview.
That means keep the glasses, hair, and
make up consistent to your normal look.
Secondly, you should keep
the focus in your face.
Make sure that your image has your
face taking up about 60% of the frame.
If you don't have a perfectly framed
picture, you can always crop it.
Your photos should also show that you
are friendly and approachable, and
be sure to select a photo that fits
with the industry's work culture.
This means if your target job is formal,
wear business attire, or if you work at
the more casual environment,
work clothing that fits this vibe.
Finally, keep the background simple.
The focus should be on you, so
opt for muted or solid colours.